neuer Tag neuer Ramadan Vlog gestern
Nacht habe ich noch einen Kuchenboden
gebacken vorbereitet für mein Rezept ist
am nächsten Tag ich liebe es das Backen
mein Hauptberuf ist das Putzen gehört
natürlich immer dazu den Kuchenboden
habe ich abgedeckt und am nächsten Tag
mein Rezept ist vorgenommen
das ist immer seine Lieblingsaufgabe
bitte gab es Rindfleisch tasian und hier
seht ihr was ein riesengroßes Opfer ich
bin statt die Pinienkerne einfach nur
anzurissen habe ich sie verbrennen
lassen cashewkern angebraten nur um sie
dann zu vergessen auf mein fette Thomas
draufzulegen zum Fastenbrechen hatten
wir dann ganz entspannt Besuch und ich
muss euch sagen dieses fette tomos Leute
es ist so lecker ich könnte mich
reinlegen haben sie diese weißen
Erdbeeren gekauft ich muss sagen es
fühlt sich extrem verboten dann ist der
generell noch keine Erdbeerzeit aber ich
weiß nicht halten soll das schmeckt
schon nach Erdbeere aber irgendwie auch
nicht und ja hier habe ich jetzt einfach
noch die Küche auf und ich habe mir noch
ganz geschmeidig einen ganz leichten
Cappuccino gegönnt wir wollen ja nicht
die Nacht zum Tag machen heute bis
morgen